Since Moon Jae-in became president, the
South Korean government has cracked down
on North Korean defectors raising
awareness of the horrors they endured
under the Kim regime. North Korea is
responsible for the deaths of millions by
starvation. It has imprisoned tens of
thousands in political gulags, and Kim
Jong Un arguably runs the cruelest
tyranny in the world. It's no wonder that
each year, more than 1,000 North Koreans
risk their lives to escape. But instead
of praising defectors for highlighting
these abuses, the democratically-elected
Moon government has chosen to silence
them as part of its policy of rapprochement
with the North. Moon's government has
repeatedly asked defectors to stop
criticizing North Korea as it did during
the 2018 Olympics, but it doesn't stop there.
It has allegedly used security services
to spy on defectors; denied their human
rights groups access to government
support; proposed textbook edits that
minimize North Korea's military
provocations; and prevented defectors
from sending information pamphlets about
South Korea across the border. The goal
of bringing peace to the Korean
Peninsula is a noble one, but
prioritizing unification over human
freedom is not the answer.
Do you think South Korea should do more
to support North Korean defectors? Let us
know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like to see our
scholars cover in 60 seconds, and be sure
to like and subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.